sur ces images amateur filmée par un
gilet jaune ils sont une centaine venus
interpellé hier le sénateur françois
patriat devant son domicile
le parlementaire a pris le parti d'aller
à leur contact pour débattre pendant une
bonne partie de l'après midi les élus se
doivent d'être à la hauteur des gens à
la portée des gens te dire répondent à
leurs attentes et comprenant qu'il
venait à mon domicile je me serais mal
vus ont fermé j'ai préféré bonnes
volontés écouter parfois lors leurs
injures écouter leurs insultes mais
aussi écouter leurs demandes et écouter
aussi leurs problèmes
écoutez oui mais il aurait préféré que
cela se fasse dans d'autres conditions
il regrette cette intrusion dans sa vie
privée quand je suis chez moi je
voudrais qu'on respecte qu'on respecte
qu'on respecte la forme d'intimité et ma
famille eux ne le comprennent pas comme
tel et pour eux y a pas de tabou ya pas
l'aîné jean michel chez rita faisait
justement partie des gilet jaune présent
il estime que cette action est
totalement légitime dans la mesure où on
s'est présenté devant son domicile et
que lui est sorti est venu à notre
rencontre
on n'a pas dû être trop intrusif je
pense pas c'est la seule des solutions
on en aura pas de réponse on ne peut pas
avoir de réponse et en discute pas
directement face à face mais encore
faut-il qu'un dialogue se rendre au
domicile des élus est devenu depuis
quelques semaines un nouveau mode
d'action des gilet jaune le mois dernier
par exemple certains avaient tenté
d'approcher la maison secondaire de
benjamin griveaux en saône et loire
il en avait été dissuadé par les forces
de l'ordre